Skylar Mays: I always tap his locker, just like it was in high school.
It hits me every time.
Fay Sims: Him and Wayde laced up next to each other.
Their lockers were side by side for years.
Skylar mentioned that everything to him feels different.
It’s—it just feels different.
Wayde was the only child.
He just always had a big heart, even as a child
He never wanted you mad at him.
You know, he was just a bundle of joy
I just noticed how much everyone gravitated toward
him because he was just so friendly to everybody.
He made everybody feel like they were special.
Once we were able to get on the same AAU team.
That's when I first started to hang around him.
I just knew that was somebody that I wanted to be like
and somebody I wanted to be around as much as possible.
All right, Skylar Mays here with small forward/power forward/center
Gatorade Player of the Year, Wayde Sims.
- How you doin’, guys?
- All right, you know, I like to get kinda personal in my interviews
so I wanna ask you, how's Leslie doin’?
Leslie Slaughter, your girlfriend.
- Oh, that's my girlfriend, that's my girl.
You know, we doin’ pretty good.
That's it.
- You guys had, like, a good chemistry.
You guys joked around a lot with each other.
You guys balanced each other out a little bit.
Describe your relationship with him.
- Yeah, I like to say it's kind of a yin and yang.
I'm more of a, you know, steady guy, and
he's just the flamboyant person who does a lot of
theatrics that everybody, you know, loves, and
he keeps everybody easygoing.
So I think that was really beneficial for me
and helped me be myself but also open up.
- Wayde took Skylar’s brothers and sisters
as his siblings, and they accepted
Wayde, like, as their brother.
- We got to a point where I coached him
and then I had to turn him over to somebody else, and
just to see him grow, we were all happy and excited.
Fay: I think he always knew that he was—I think he was just tryin’ to play me.
I secretly prayed that he would stay here and go to LSU.
I remember one day he just kinda entertained maybe going
somewhere off, and I was
like, “Oh god, no, please.”
- And I’m excited to be playin’
basketball at LSU next year.
Wayne: It was exciting to me, bein’ a dad and a former player.
It's always an honor to see your kid go in your footsteps.
- Did Wayde's commitment here affect yours?
- Absolutely, absolutely. I loved playin’ with Wayde.
We knew each other’s game in and out.
You know, we played with each other for 10, 12-plus years.
So, wanted to keep it goin’.
- How did the bond between you guys evolve
once you got to college, once you got to LSU?
- Um...definitely grew stronger. I think we—the more we
were around each other, our, just, relationship
just grew every day.
Mays: When Coach would get on us pretty bad, he was the one
who would kinda ease everything up.
I think he was a glue guy in the way he played because
he played to make other guys better.
He played to win.
You know, anybody likes to play with
somebody like that, so.
It was so effortless for him to
help this team win games.
- Members of the LSU basketball
team are grieving tonight.
- Cellphone video shows the moments
before Wayde Sims was shot.
- I got the phone call in the middle of the
night, and I just remember us racing to the hospital
and, um...and then it—I don't know.
I really don't remember, like, a whole lot.
I actually don't remember all of the month of October or November.
- I was sleeping.
It was pretty early.
Obviously that woke me up and, I
mean, that day was for the most part a blur.
- I was just prayin’ to God that he would
be all right. Um, you know, that—
I know he was shot. You know, just
I would hope that, you know, he would survive.
We got there or whatever, but, you
know, unfortunately wasn’t—
- We begin with the tragedy hitting
the Baton Rouge sports world.
LSU basketball star Wayde
Sims, shot and killed overnight.
- I just paused for a minute and just
kinda sat back; like, I was in shock and disbelief.
And I just couldn't stop crying.
I didn't know what to do.
I called my parents because my parents
are obviously close with Wayde like his
are with me, and, um...
And just cried.
- I feel like everyone who
knew Wayde...I mean—
Everyone who knew Wayde knew
that he just smiled all the time.
Just a loving person, and
his smile was contagious
For me, it kinda feels like he’s just on
a really long vacation and he forgot his phone here.
It's just, it's just really hard for me.
It's hard for all of us.
- My heart breaks for Skylar. I mean, it just, it just breaks for Skylar.
He checks on me, and I'll check on him, and
we’ll just try to, you know, keep in touch.
But, you know, I feel like I'm dying in the inside but, you
know, I just—my heart just aches for him as well.
Fay: It’s your worst nightmare.
So I always say that the worst thing that could have
ever happened to me has happened.
Wayde was my entire life.
How do you feel his presence as a team?
Yeah, sometimes when some shots go in in the
game, I’m like, “Yeah, that was Wayde.”
Fay: I don't feel that I could ever fill the void.
I just don't foresee that happening.
I know that I'll be empty, I
say for the rest of my life.
My heart has a hole, and I tell him it bleeds every day.
I don't ever see that being repaired.
I know by the grace of God, He could
change, you know, situations, but I
just—right now I can't see that.